la pire tornade convient de voir est
avec nous il fait partie de nos invités
avec jacques legras mais aussi avec les
dames
micheline dax et colette brosset alors
colette brosset vous venez de nous
expliquer dans dans le sujet de pascal
d'où venait le nom des branquignols dans
les braquer les branquignols racontez
nous un peu maintenant comment est née
cette troupe comment c'est un petit
miracle que les gens se réunissent comme
ça c'est une histoire de conservatoire
de copan conservatoire et je crois qu'au
départ robert était vraiment pas tout à
fait normal je viens de le dire est
qu'il était très attiré par les freins
les autres un ormeau autour de nous il
avait décidé je crois aussi que on
sortait de la guerre on sortait d'une
occupation épouvantable et on avait
envie d'éclater d'exploser on était
jeunes et pas mal de ils étaient tous
foudre j'ai beaucoup de visiteurs alors
vous attendez on va parler du gilet de
l'extérieur alors michel vous avez comme
une chanteuse
la chanteuse classique et moi j'ai cru
que j'allais jouer un spectacle
dramatique trouvaient à bord rick oui
j'ai été la première surprise il alors
après s'être salaires folie était
contagieuse je suppose que bon me suis
tombé dedans car les rencontres
j'allais dire tout le monde est passé
c'est incroyable de de funès quart mais
tout le monde est passé à ce qu'est
robert avait brouillé may be les bons
comédiens s quoi il avait bon goût pour
les chevaliers
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez inventé
vous êtes inspiré de quoi votre avis des
des grands clubs des grands peut-être du
muet c'est très visuel à l'aide
composteur keaton charlie chaplin buster
keaton tout ce qu'on a bien connu là bas
près et vous inspiriez des sketches
visuel comment ça se passe et comment
travaillez-vous nyon revers trouvais que
c'était pas la peine de parler si ce
n'était pour dire claudel ou molière
c'est elle m'a tellement nécessaire il
aimait le comique sans texte
alors il ya simulation il ya plein
d'anecdotes vous avez vécu tellement
d'années ensemble moi j'aimerais que
pierre tornade nous raconte un peu cette
aventure à laquelle mais c'est quand
même très sérieux jeu réalisé par don de
dieu j'ignorais à ce coin là vous avez
joué à broadway pendant combien de temps
quelqu'un prend près de 80 succès à
broadway pour des français assez
rarissime
withera alors pierre tornade vous
l'angleterre vous aimiez les états unis
ça a été le bonheur vous avez juste un
petit problème de langue oui je le suis
rien la new york jets toute beauté
j'avais pas fait l'angleterre avec g g
type k1 marche moi je jouais en malade
au cerbère nuls chercher dans cette
pièce pendant menés en amérique je suis
arrivé à la meije parlait pas très bien
anglais
et puis bon ben c'est un hôtel
l'ouverture d'une petite cuisine dans
les années 2000 quand je suis descendue
m'acheter une bonne boîte de conserve à
manger je l'ouvré sur sérieusement se
passe à la poêle
j'étais très appétissant sa présenter un
plat fumant créé des coloris vous
retrouver vous disent que penses-tu
d'amérique c'est le drame des 100 me
voir dans ma chambre je me disais tu
marches du rugby c'est pas très bon
c'est dégueulasse que sais je prends le
temps va mon club je met du sel du
poivre y aura cherché partout belle la
boîte il dit mais cela de la nourriture
pour chien j'ai mangé de tellement en
colère et moment ce jeudi à jouer un
coup de téléphone a donné et tout je ne
trouve pas ton téléphone il est par la
fenêtre je ne comprends rien je vais
jeter par la fenêtre du cac très visuel
alors un philadelphie jacques lebrun est
ce que vous allez retourner partout
c'était le début c'était le 13 août
avant avant de new york
alors on essayé tous les jours on
changeait de jack layton notre directeur
de producteurs vous nous dit il faut
changer tel ce qu'est ce que mais plutôt
à telle place très à telle place et tous
les jours on changeait et j'étais le
seul à noter vraiment l'ordre du
spectacle et chaque soir je mettais le
nouvel ordre dans mon chapeau
haut-de-forme bien sûr à chanter c'était
le seul à noter les autres compter sur
moi pour la suivre et puis tu as
vraiment que la cour de spectacles
moment j'avais à sa levée colette et je
lui fais ma lame et d'un mot chapeau
s'est vu une famille parfait comme ça
c'est dans la salle de l'envol est ce
que c'est un ordre de sketches on sea
des bombes à partir de 7 ans on va
improviser un voyageur que mme x émis à
15 est passé dans les rangs s'il vous
plaît pour essayer de récupérer ces
attaques
enfin ça a été au début on a continué à
porter maintenant sur le comique z
apporter vraiment quelque chose aux
comics maintenant il ya eu d'autres
choses qui sont nés il ya des réponses
de l'atlantide et vous pensez que tout
cas une chose qui nous surprend quand on
revoit des branquignols aujourd'hui je
vois qu'on pour préparer cette émission
dans les salles de montage autres tout
le monde rit c'est très actuelle vous
avez la sensation de 2,7
vous perpétuez cela même les enfants moi
c'est ce qui m'a frappé on a fait une
projection dans un cinéma donc sur un
grand écran il ya un 1 devant un public
complètement neuf des enfants qui ne
connaissait même pas le nom de
branquignols et qui ont ri c'est
formidable
il va chez vous proposer un reportage
maman qui va vous intéresser c'est faire
justement quel regard portent les jeunes
sur vous avec six comédiens à tenter de
se convaincre qu'ils allaient rester
avec nous parce que ses comédiens ont
décidé vingt ans après vos derniers
spectacles c'était 74 environ 120 en un
peu plus de vingt ans après vous l'aviez
spectacle est bien des comédiens désire
reprendre votre répertoire stéphane
haumant didier renquet reportage
quand on veut jouer au branquignols
mieux vaut commencer par se répartir les
rôles
monsieur jean louis b
spectateurs bonsoir sa part moi je serai
le spectateur d'honneur ces comédiens
ont l'âge d'être les petits enfants des
branquignols historique
ils ne les ont jamais vus sur scène
seulement à la télévision plus de vingt
ans après ils veulent reprendre leur
grand classique
m
on connaît ça mais parce que nos parents
nous ont parlé il ya beaucoup de gens de
notre génération qui connaissent pas ça
du tout et on a vraiment envie de faire
découvrir sa est partagé ça avec les
gens de notre génération qui connaissent
pas simple les branquignols originaux
ont révélé toute une génération de
comiques attiré par le burlesque et
l'absurde remonter ses sketches le pari
est amusant mais risqué les gens
n'auront qu'une idée c'est tient à oui
c'est la reprise des branquignols 1 mais
c'est pas les branquignols bon justement
c'est ça aussi c'est davantage de
reprendre un petit peu ça et de dire ok
si les banques lyneel sont d'accord pour
que nous le reprenne pourquoi pourquoi
pas être aussi bons qu'eux voire
meilleur quoi les branquignols ont fait
des émules bien au delà nos frontières
car leurs gags visuels sont très proches
de l'humour anglais il était tellement
en osmose avec cet humour là qu'ils ont
été pillés parce que quand on regarde
certaines séquences de béni l'on
retrouve beaucoup de choses qui étaient
chez les branquignols par les jeunes
comédiens vont donc se roder en province
avant paris et puis qui sait peut-être
un jour rejouer au quel regard portez
vous sur ce succès sur ça vous un
dépotoir
oui cette énergie est bien il arrive
encore à plaire au public actuel la
question de trait français canton
mobinil qui a fait un succès sur france
3 on se dit c'est nouveau c'est british
c'est vraiment quelque chose il a
inventé quelque chose parce que ben il
finalement c'est pas complètement
inspiré de ce que vous avez été là bas
avec nous il a fait il existait en même
temps
il était déjà ce qu'on appelle un
comédien dans l'onglet et nous appliquer
pas mal de choses intimes alors
dites-moi est-ce que l'avenir d'abord je
vous demander votre maturité
si vous êtes tous encore très avait très
vite très vite alors je vais jouer à
partir du 23 de ce mois donc à
saint-maur vous partez en tournée avec
les spectacles de miel avec une pièce
qui s'appelle l'audi match je sais pas
si vous voyez alors nous sommes tous
visés deux revers l'amiable et non plus
pas de danger vous mais avoue une mise
en scène de françois guérin et nous
partons entre autres avec un à lionel et
jacques du bi et toute la france la
belgique la suisse
pierre tornade on vous voit sur france 2
très souvent commencé avec du marchand
bientôt encore ses films de la série
nestor burma et l'onu qu'est ce qui se
passe dans ce domaine
moi je croise les vient de l'est var
dans ces îles sont pas tous du bon pied
je vais peut-être aller faire ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle
eh ben j'ai terminé un hommage au
printemps avec michel ancel et c'est au
montage pense que ça va passer sur la
chaîne bien c'est bien j'espère que ça
va encourager tout le monde avait dans
les théâtres à le voir tout ce qui se
passe de boue notamment qu'il peut être
oui oui moi j'ai treize années de
françois morel qui est merveilleux
comité se font envie d'aller dans les
théâtres aller voir tout ce qui est bien
en ce moment puisque le foot fait
relâche vous avez vu la transition de
quoi